hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar
monoclonality
assurance using clone select single cell
printer
and clone select imager in human stem
cell engineering workflow
i am michelle ashton of labrutz and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminars is
presented by lab roots
and brought to you by molecular devices
to learn more
visit moleculardevices.com we encourage
you to participate today
by submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation you may
also submit any technical
issues here as well if you have trouble
seeing
or hearing the presentation this webinar
is educational and thus offers free
continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window
at the bottom of your screen to obtain
your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
gargee roy
scientist too at astrazeneca
on the stem cell therapy team in the
department of bioprocess
development gargey you may now begin
your presentation
thank you michel for the introduction
and thank you to lab roots and
molecular devices for giving me this
opportunity
to talk about our work
around monoclonality assurance using
clone select
single cell printer and clone select
imager
in human stem cell engineering workflow
so before i go into
um the my presentation in the
stem cell area i thought i'll take a
uh you know brief moment and introduce
myself
to you regarding like the um
my background uh where i came from how i
um transitioned into the
stem cell um workspace
so as i uh um scientist my career grew
in astrazeneca around
um technology uh evaluation for
protein exploration so i um
you know saw many aspects of it and
published
some of our data as well it ranges from
developing
a reporter system for detecting
um ear stress in cho
cells during igg expression we also
um dealt into um validating
the climax technology developed by
probiogen for
generating the effusive antibodies
from geo cells and also very recently
our publication in maps
um describes about development of a high
yielding expression platform
for the introduction of non-natural
amino acids in protein sequences
so these are very diverse topics as you
can see
but there is one thing that is common in
all of them that is the
high throughput screening and that's
what i bring in into the stem cell works
best
so um
before i go to the um you know the next
um
slide which is um
the um it's it's about
the um there is a lag i'm seeing so
that's why
bear with me on that before it goes the
slide
goes live but anyway i will be talking
about
um this piece of work that we published
a few years ago
that came out in journal of
immunological methods
it's from a life campaign and we gave
um you know a commercial viability to a
product
by increasing the productivity
by almost twofold using the strength of
clone pixel
this is the publication where we also
reported the monoclonality assessment
offered by clone pixel
and we reported that it takes about two
rounds
to um you know get a
monoclonal cell line and i'm glad that
based on these findings molecular
devices redesigned
their later um generation
clone peaks and that they added
a um you know imaging component to it
so that way it you can really make sure
that you are getting your clone coming
out of a single cell
so it's just not that um the reason i
bring up
this publication to the context of stem
cells that
clone pixel was working as a workhorse
for many years in my workflow
however when i started working with the
stem cells
before even i knew that how different
these cell types can be
so i used the same technology and put
out the cells
on the semi-solid matrix and
i do not have an image to show you what
i ended up with
but i realized that i need to think
differently
and at that time i'm talking about like
in almost two and a half years ago when
i transitioned into the
stem cell um field so
um obviously i you know now they have a
machine designed
for stem cells but at that time we did
not have anything in hand
so um that starts my journey like
thinking different
things differently from joe cells and i
almost had to
you know turn my brain 180 degrees to
understand these cells
and to get to know them and you know
be productive in this area
so um you know before i go uh again
in my um the part of my talk i want to
give you an update on the um
you know what are these cells the ipscs
and dses
they both are pluripotent cells but
there is a major difference between them
that the is derived from
any somatic cell whereas the yes is from
its name
they derive from the embryonic stem
cells
the ipscs uh it's a revolutionary
invention from dr yamanaka and
colleagues
only back in 2006 they discovered that
by introducing four transcription
factors
you can convert any
mature cell to a pluripotent cell and
you can differentiate them
into many various cell types obviously
that discovery not only
rewarded him with a nobel prize but it
opened up
the entire field of regenerative
medicine to its enormous
possibility so i'll be covering
the differences that these pluripotent
stem cells
have when it comes to the
in context of clonal outgrowth from
single cells so
in my next slide here i'll be covering
um about the outline the presentation
on the um the um
you know this is the uh modest outline
of what i'll be covering
in this um talk i'll be introducing you
to the
clone select single cell printer a
general
workflow the ease and difficulties of
the single cell printing
and clonal outgrowth the differences in
outgrowth efficiencies between the ipsc
and esc
obviously i'll touch base on the
monoclonality assessment
and i'll talk about the clonal
characterization as well
so um
this is actually um it shows um
a video um from my
um own uh you know experiment
and i apologize for the background noise
this is coming out
of um the blower in in inside of a bsc
um what i want you to uh you know pay
attention in this slide that
um you know this this uh clone select uh
the single cell printer is um a pretty
simple
design this is a microfluidics based um
based system and um also
it is um you know it has two cameras
here as it moves
and dispenses cells from well to l and
each of those images
actually um our
cell principle printed cells actually
generate a
um you know five images as you can see
here
at the bottom left bottom corner of the
cells and the fourth image actually
captures
the cell that is going to be um you know
dropped uh
into into the well it's a very simple
design
and it's uh the no no
high energy lasers are involved in this
model
and it's as gentle as hand pipetting
and it doesn't require any high highly
skilled professional to operate the
system
anyone trained with the system can
operate it and
do the single cell printing and the
dispensing
volume is as little as 200 picoliter
only
and that doesn't actually create any
waste or anything it gets just sucked
out
um and you know diminished sucked out by
air
and what i really want to emphasize is
the exclusion criteria that it
applies in the in in printing of the
cells
and that actually based on the shape
size
access ratio of the cells and which are
very very important
and adds really high quality in the
printed cells
and that actually ends up being uh you
know growing up and
um and you you get your plenty of cells
to characterize and get
the you know very clone that uh you uh
hope for
so um this is actually a slide that
outlines um you know a very simplistic
workflow that you can start with um
any cell population it can be your
parental cell if you want to pronounce
something out of it
or it can be an engineered cell that you
want to you know
engineer to um you know
to to make the cells of any desired
property that you would wish so it can
be anything
but obviously the cells that you print
and that grows out into colony um you
want to screen them with the battery of
genotypic phenotypic
um assays and this is actually a very
very critical step
and that happens only after you expand
your cell population from
96 well into 24 to 6 well and
even into larger vessel size but once
you
you know have a subset of population
that you like
obviously at the end of your
characterization you would like to
make sure that they are pluripotent
and they can differentiate into any cell
type that you desire
them to be so
uh moving on this is actually um you
know a snapshot from
um our one of our very first experiment
where we um you know made a cell
suspension put it in the cartridge and
wanted to print out
uh we wanted to print like you know five
different 96 wall plates
and uh what you can see here there is a
decline in the colony outgrowth
efficiency the y-axis
represents the colony outgrowth in each
96 well plate
that we printed in and i like to mention
here
that um one of the the consumables here
in this process those little cartridges
they are actually quite expensive
and that's something we wanted to make
sure that we don't waste and you know we
get the
the most out of the worth of our you
know expenditure
um so obviously we see that there is
something wrong in our experimental
design right here
that there is a steady drop in the um
colony outgrowth efficiency when we go
from plate one or two
and down to number five but however
um you know the outgrowth efficiency
overall
for these ipsc cells in this experiment
was
um really uh beyond my expectations
because coming from your background i
know how difficult it can be sometimes
to grow those cells from
single cells however the being the cho
cells being very robust isn't then
it's it's it can be challenging however
if we just
average the outgrowth efficiency here uh
which shows with the
you know dark green bar to the right of
the chart
and that's the average that is still
hitting like around 40 percent and
overall you know i can only i could only
be
pleased with this the outcome of this
experiment
moving on when we actually
tried the same experiment
setup for the um
for ipscs in acf condition
the scf stands for the animal component
free
condition because this is highly
essential when
and becoming more and more critical
because
as we develop our cell therapy products
for human
therapeutics we need to have processes
um entirely and male component free
but as you can see here that there is a
sharp decline
in the colony outgrowth efficiency when
the same cells were
pushed to grow in animal component or
xeno
free condition and xenophocondition
and like i just showed again there is a
drop
in the colony outgrowth efficiency from
plate one into plate four
and um there were like you know for each
each of these conditions i tried to
plate like five plus per condition but
in
in case of the condition one and two
there were no outgrowth for uh platform
and five
so obviously it shows that there is a
problem
in our experiment setup
moving on i was actually
then go into the you know the back end
of the data that was collected and we
could see
that as we moved from plate 1 to plate
4 that there is a drop in the colony
outgrowth efficiency however the purple
bursts
show that there is a an increase
in in time in plating time
so that means so and i i should actually
uh
mention here that um the cartridges that
are used for this technology
are very very tiny you only um
can load like 70 microliters 70 75
microliters of your cell suspension
and made at about 1
million per cell cell density
but however uh it normally takes about
two to five minutes to print one
uh you know 96 well plate but as
time goes and the cells being in that um
you know protein free medium so which
is just you know more pbs in this case
because of the size tiny size of the
cuvettes
um you know it's it's uh desirable
uh to stay away from the bubbles for
efficient cell printing
and so that is why we use only 1x pbs
obviously with in presence of the rock
inhibitors
to keep the cells alive however
um you know the cells the cell viability
drops but um for most part of
our work process we were actually
you know staying focused to first two
plates only
but uh later on we could overcome this
challenge by just
replenishing the cell suspension with
fresh cell suspension
and that way um you know you can
plate up to 10 plates i mean that's the
max we went to
you may be able to do even more
so that's actually a um you know an
important
point for the um the cell printing
i wanted to um mention uh in this talk
so moving on um as we um
so um this chart actually summarizes
uh about what i just presented
about the differences in the colony
outgrowth efficiency
between the um you know this templates
matrigel condition
which is very very permanency for any
ips
cell line most of the ibs's aligns um
however when we go from the stimulus to
any of the
sef condition there is a struggle the
cells actually you know
do not want to grow in those conditions
and this is an
area that i want to highlight that the
field
you know as scientists we need to pay
more attention
i'm sure um there is work going on
around this area
and we'll get solution to this um you
know very impor
important aspect in coming years
so um
so in this slide actually this is
actually a um
um i like to show the the quality
of the um the colonies that grow out
um out of those cells that were printed
um
in 96 wells and um
you can you can appreciate that they
have
very uh very much like the you know ipsc
morphology
with the uh distinct ages and they are
actually
really high quality ipsc that grow out
from those uh single cell printed
um cells in 96 wells and also i'd like
to bring it to your attention that you
see
the black dots that you see those are
actually some of the
hypocritic cells and that happens when
the colonies actually grow out to
a good size however i've seen it made
differ between ipsc line to ipc line
however like if you harvest yourself
anywhere between day eight and eight and
you can actually
avoid some of those to happen and also
it is essential
at that time point you know from day six
onwards when the colonies actually
are big enough to um you know to feed
them
on a daily basis so that they don't run
out of the nutrients
and start you know that spontaneous
differentiation
so it depends on your the robustness of
the cell line you're working with
but the harvest day uh kind of varies
between day eight
to day ten however
when we go into the um you know the the
clones that grow out in the
um acf condition as you see here
i do not have many images to share with
you some of them
do really um you know see get
the same um you know high quality ipsc
um characteristic but if you if you want
to take a look at this
right bottom corner that clone actually
looks very different
and some of them are actually
you know starting to differentiate um at
this very early stage
and if you pay attention to the left
bottom corner here
and you can see that there is a very
tiny colony so those
those colonies you can wait to take them
to you know attend certain stage before
you can harvest but many cases they just
die out
small so that obviously speaks about the
challenge
that the cells go through when they get
into
this animal component free condition so
that speaks for
the need for the medium development um
to to enrich to medium the composition
for these cells to grow out in animal
component free
environment so this is actually
a slide that shows um
you know the images the five images that
are captured
through the single cell printer and as i
was
saying saying in my previous um
one of the previous slides that every
single
um well actually captures like
five images and the fourth image
contains the image of the cells that
are deposited in the 96 well and just to
the right here
actually shows the ipsc clowns the high
quality ipc clones that grew out
of these single cells that are deposited
but if you look at the bottom right
corner very bottom
right corner it has a little bit of a
stretched
um you know morphology unlike the other
three
that are here on this slide and if we
actually go back and take a closer look
at the
um within that red circle you can see
that
that that a doublet was printed
um in that particular well and that
actually you know gave rise to that
stretched colony
that the colony actually is a mixture
came from a mixture of cells
so this is then very very important
aspect that once you get your clones
you characterize them and then you want
to go back
and examine these images and make sure
that your
cell population derived from a single
cell and not multiple cells
so then actually this is actually um
so now i will start talking about the
differences
we have into um between the ipscs
and escs so um
obviously the robustness of the ipscs to
grow from single cell
doesn't really reflect um you know as is
into the when we go into the ess the
black bars
in this case actually shows that um the
outgrowth efficiency
for the unengineered platform so which
is
always higher than the engineered cells
and uh even for ipsc it drops from 70
percent
to 40 percent which is still you know um
considerably high
compared to the when it comes to the
point of the esc's
and you can see and we tested like two
different esc's in this experiment
simultaneously
but one was slightly better than the
other however it's still
actually very very low and that truly
speaks for
some more work that needs to be done um
in this area but i can
uh just you know give you an update by
modifying some of the cultural
conditions
and the dissociating reagent we could
steadily
bring up this very low efficiency to
around
work around 20 or so for the engineered
cells
but obviously um you know as scientists
in the field
we like to make improvements in this
area
so then when we hit this problem and um
i obviously you know
when you have a timeline looming in your
um
on you so you have to you know get your
things going and you have to screen
large number of clones to get your
desired population
so uh limiting dilution is
um you know one way you can do it
obviously issue again
and um and these cells are actually they
grow fairly well
if you just have them in in in
just like 50 cells per ml or um
100 cells per meal in a um you know in
any size of plates six well plates then
sentimental plates omniplates or
anything you just name it the cross
feeding
do help and you can get your cells um
forming the clones and here in this case
we were actually um
you know it's a proof of concept um
study that we're running
and we ourselves were expressing the grp
and you see you can see that
some of these highly you know bright
clones are
fairly sparsed whereas some of those
actually are fairly close to together
obviously you would not you know pick
the ones that are
you know crossed out with red but you
you
easily can scoop the ones that are out
there
and you can get you know fill in your 96
whole plate will turn up close
but one caveat i found in this way um
that you can actually save your campaign
and meet your timeline but
definitely you cannot establish the
traceability of your
clone that it derived from a single cell
and
often when we um like to make our cell
therapy products for human therapeutics
and for regulatory submission
this is essential for us to prove that
our cell therapy product is um is
homogeneous and it came
homogeneous in its characteristic and it
came from a single cell
source so obviously then you know
the single cell printer comes
handy in that case as well
so here actually now um i just uh you
know
the technology that i present to you
using the single cell printer
so we we added another layer of
technology here
and that is the imagery part of it so
the es cells are unlike the two cells or
t
cells they're not perfectly round cells
they can be irregular
and they're very sticky as well even
though
we are getting the images like five
images that you get
and you can actually you know say that
you you do have
one cell printed but if what if like you
know there are two cells
just have the same morphology and
excess ratio and roundness and they're
just one behind the other and instead of
one cell you printed two cells
so we wanted to make sure that our cells
are really printed
as single cells and that's why this um
clone selective measure actually uh came
very handy to to to develop our process
and here actually to the right i can
show you that you can
capture um that two cells were printed
and the images were captured like um
you know 24 hours um later
than the cell printing and that's why
you can see that your printed cell
actually divided overnight
and these cells have a doubling time of
20-24 hours
and those two cells that you see here
actually
you know grew later on and within 10
days they formed this beautiful
um you know gop expressing colony in
this case
so um and so that's that's what i want
to stress here
that for the monoclonality establishing
the monoclonality we
we truly added this um clone selective
measure in our
work work um flow to make sure
that we are printing you know a single
cells
are printed in our 96 volt plate and i
like to mention that here
that um the new generation of the clone
selective measures actually they have
improved optics and you you really can
you know visualize single cells that are
printed
on the matrix and um to the top left
corner
it's a it's it's an image of an epsilon
that's a new addition to our workflow
and i'm excited to get you know um i'll
start working with that
for our um stencil therapy
um you know team and moving on
it actually as you can see here it may
sound like you know it's uh you know
it's a simple process
and you really um can print cells in
single cells
however um you know it may not be as
easy as it
sounds and it took me actually um
five campaigns to come to this point
and capture single cell images and that
is because of the timing
the timing sense that if you wait too
long
then your cells start dividing and you
miss this opportunity
if you centrifuge your plate after cell
printing
you lose the cell viability and you get
like very little
colony out growth but then actually if
it's the best that if you can allow the
cells to settle down
and um in the uh by gravity
and then you come back and you know
image your plate by clone selective
measure
and then you can actually you know
really detect the single cells on the
matrix
even if you cannot detect that no day of
your cell printing but if you
use barcodes on your plates and you
image your plates
few you know several days during between
yourself printing and the harvest day
of day 10 or 12 then actually
the the the software recognizes your
plate
and it actually you know and draws a
growth carb
so once you have a mature colony grow
out and then you can actually trace back
and get the images of the single cell it
is a really
nice technology i enjoy it myself
discovering that well
my clone came came from a single cell
and obviously you know it takes some
expertise to get to this
you know decision of the imaging and
um at the end with the improved uh
optics
uh the csi actually adds tremendous
value
to the monoclonality assurance in our
esc ipsc workflow
and uh so once you get the cells that
are printed
and you make sure that they are uh
pluripotent
then obviously uh they are monoclonal
but obviously you want to make sure that
they are genotypically
you know stable to the left here
actually i'm showing
a depending karyotype of one of the
clones
we have actually using this method we
used
we generated like hundreds of clones and
we have
tremendous amount of data that shows
that the cells that come out
of these um you know single cell printer
are of very high quality and um they are
general typically stable just not
at the beginning and they actually go
through
i mean even for many generations and
they are highly pluripotent you can
differentiate them
into the three germ layers like the
endoderm mesoderm ectoderm
here i have the images from the cells
that are printed
by a single cell printer and
differentiated them into different
charm layers and stained them for the
germ layer specific markers and you can
see the beautiful immunostaining of
those
and this is not that i hope you can
appreciate
that the same jp expressing clone that i
was uh mentioning in my
um you know previous slide they're
actually
displayed here as well and i was able to
push them to differentiate them into
um a uh you know beating cardiomyocyte
so um this is a very very fulfilling
moment
for me for validating this technology
for
in the esc and ipsc workspace
and we are actually um routinely using
it
for um in our in our
workflow uh for the esc and ipsc space
and in the end actually i'll just
summarize um
uh our work here and i'd like to
emphasize the fact that the clone select
a single cell printer is an effective
tool for
single cell isolation of the ipsc and
esc's
and combination of the clone select
imager and the clone select
printer offers the confirmation of the
monoclonality assessment
and the cells that are printed using the
chrome
select single cell printer is of
very high quality and they are of
they are pluripotent and they can be
differentiated
into many various cell types you just
name it i just showed you uh an example
of the
cardiomyocyte between cardiomyocyte but
you can differentiate them into
renal cells and kidney cells liver cells
nerve cells muscle cells
any cells a cell type that you name it
but i
at the end i do i do like to emphasize
that we need to do more work
in the field to further optimize the
outgrowth efficiency for the esc and
ips's in the animal
component free environment so that
we can bring the you know
therapies uh regenerative um cell
therapy
products um to the benefit of the
patients down the road
and um this is actually um
my big thank you to the big team of
people
that helped in um
from to to validate this technology and
this is a
very very diverse group um that i'm
extremely thankful of and um also
i like to thank our external
collaborators
in yfl research institute we wanted to
make sure that the cells that are
printed
are genetically stable and they are
general typically um
you know their karyotypes are normal so
um
um we are we are tremendously thankful
for providing very high quality data
from voice
research scientists from sumergen uh for
some of the
validating some of the gene edited cell
lines and
a big thanks to um molecular devices
for getting these uh you know
technologies um
to us and i'll call out paula and
joe um uh you know that
tremendously um indebted to them um joe
actually maintains
uh uh he's a engineer and we work
closely with
he maintains the systems in a very
pristine condition
that they perform he makes sure that
they perform at close the hundred
percent
and uh so that we do not have you know
any frustration grow
growing and uh you know we get the very
efficient cell printing
and we are really really pleased with
the quality we get and
paula is actually she's tireless in
teaching
this very intricate um you know
technology
and um i'm indebted to heart that you
know i could learn
and effectively use this technology to
to our process and um i'm immensely
thankful
also to our easy soul therapy leadership
team for bringing these technologies to
us so that we can efficiently generate
therapies
for um for our patients and
last but not least um i will thank
all of you who joined who could join
this webinar
and i'll take any questions that you may
have um
and i'll try my best to address your
questions thank you all
thank you for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
all right let's go ahead and get started
okay so our first question is
lifting ips c cells can be a bit tricky
do you have any techniques you may share
regarding best
practices for lifting cells
um yes i think it is a very relevant and
tricky question
and um having these cells you know
pretty translucent in appearance it's
sometimes difficult
so and um what i like to
you know emphasize on the fact that um
you can use uh any dissociation reagents
like
the acute is or virgin or
any any reagent but what i prefer myself
to use
um is edtf the enzyme free
um reagents because oftentimes for you
know what i
fist that the cells may lose
their attachment uh you know um
they may become like spontaneously loose
and may not want to
attach at this very early stage of the
colony forming stage
so um you can actually use you know any
dtfree
um reagent and once you
you know do it if you if you hold your
plate against
the um the light you can see the colony
which is
which is tricky i admit but uh
nevertheless what you can do
is like you know if you're not sure if
you are collecting a you know
a big large number of cells you can add
the very list add some media put the
self
source split back to the uh you know
incubator
next you can come back and check your um
you know recovery
and then if you are not satisfied with
your recovery you can go back and you
know
use your plate again so that's how you
can get a really
really you know high highly efficient um
cell recovery
okay thank you okay your next question
typically after printing a single cell
how frequently do you feed them
um obviously um like if you
are using rock inhibitor in your um
you know a medium during cell printing
you would want to remove the rock
inhibitor and do a complete medium
exchange
24 hours later your cell printing
but to replenish them with the right
nutrients you can skip a couple of days
and i typically do like day three
day five and from day six onwards i put
them
um you know on a daily basis so that if
if some of the clones are growing faster
than expected so that you might want to
make sure that they don't
run out of the nutrients growing in that
little you know pretty tight condition
so that you know that that typically
helps
okay thank you now what percent of your
single cells grow out to single colonies
it depends on the um you know
um whether you're using ipsc or
esc obviously um you can see
a um you know higher output efficiency
of our ipscs which can go like anywhere
between 40 to 70 percent
however for esc that percentage is
fairly low
so it's at the highest we've got is
around 20 percent i would think
so um you know that is there is a
challenge that lies for the
yes is to grow out at um high
high efficiency
thank you garvey we have time for one
last question
have you recognized a cost savings in
the amount of consumables used compared
to traditional limiting dilution
um this is a very good question and
as i was covering um you know in my
during my talk
that um limiting dilution works very
well for these cells but there is no
traceability
uh of your um you know for for you to
confirm that your
uh cell product came from
uh single cell so for the uh you know
benefit
of of your product and the life of the
product
um you know even though the cartridges
are little expensive
but it is worth using this technology
and validate that your you know your
cell therapy product
that um you know if the monoclonal
monoclonality assurance is um important
for your downstream application so you
know i do recognize there is a cost
associated with it but it's all worth it
thank you cargi do you have any final
comments for our audience before we go
today
well um obviously i'm thankful to
everyone who could join
this webinar you know taking the time
out of their
business schedule i'm immensely thankful
to them and
um i really appreciate um you know the
fields
moving so fast and we are actually
getting
the technologies um you know um moving
uh you know at the same or even faster
pace
and getting these valuable technologies
um
available to the researchers so that we
can make
a life-changing medicine for the
patients in the regenerative
medicine space a big thanks to you all
well thank you again garcia roy for your
time today
and we would also like to thank labruz
and our sponsor molecular devices
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye